he's an English singer-songwriter and
occasional actor in 2014 he was
nominated for Best New Artist at the
56th Annual Grammy Awards he received
the songwriter of the Year award in 2015
he's ed Sheeran and here are his top ten
rules for success carrying on the
momentum I think that's the biggest
challenge for any artist you know like
to get to get up to a stadium level for
four for any artists that is kind of the
peak but then the challenge from there
is staying at that level you know to
remain at the stadium level to keep
releasing records that not necessarily a
hits but just connects with people you
know I don't I've I've never been
worried about my record selling millions
of copies but I have been really intent
on writing songs that come from me but
when they go out they belong to people
and their people can relate to them and
get into it and then then they'll come
to the shows the show's always the end
goal the album I see an album as a as a
commercial to a show you buy the album
or download the album or streaming the
album or however you listen to the album
and then you think I want to go and see
in life and then you guys the show yeah
I guess my advice for young performance
is just just do you like there's seven
billion people in this world and there
was no one like you and there's no one
he's gonna write songs like you know and
he's gonna sing like you as long as you
keep it exactly yourself I mean imitate
people to a point to get your inputs and
kind of help you write songs and help
you learn guitar and help you sing but
once you've found your voice just do
that and stick with it and even if it
sounds like it's odd and people are
telling you it won't work just stick
with it and eventually it will because
there's seven billion people in the
world there's bound to be one person
that likes music have you ever heard of
this theory about the 10,000 hours
theories so that theory works right so
when I when I first started out I saw
Damien Rice in concert and I mention it
in a song I was said I went stops and my
name's and lights stadium heights with
Damien Rice and literally like I watched
him and was like I want to do that one
day
I wrote million songs did a million gigs
and have ended up kind of doing a
similar thing but it literally came from
writing a song a day or two songs a day
or five songs a day and just getting all
these songs out of me
doing a million gigs sometimes three
gigs a day so we did six gigs a day one
year at Glastonbury but I think you view
it as a dirty tap when you switch dirty
tap on it's going to flows get water out
for a substantial amount of time and
then clean waters going to start flowing
and now and then you'll get a bit but as
long as it gets out you it's fine
so with songs you're going to write
songs at the beginning you are my songs
were terrible my raps would set like
I've listened to it the other day it's
awful but I got it out of me and the
more and more you write the more and
more you experience since then you start
flowing clean water and song start
getting better and better and better
when you just you're on a good streak
you're writing good songs now and then
you're going to write a song and that
song is out of you and you can move on
and it's the same with gigs like you
will always play bad gigs at the
beginning that's what you need to do and
then the more gigs you do the better you
will get now and then you'll have a gig
but that's alright because you've got it
out of you and you've experienced it so
I just say the more and more you can do
you put put in your 10,000 hours
bridesmaid songs as possible gig as much
as possible what I've learnt about music
today is um no one has to buy your
record anymore like no one has to
usually they buy a record of you're a
likeable person
Adele's incredibly likable Taylor's
incredibly likeable Bruno Mars isn't
going to like a Sam Smith's like why I'd
like to think I was likable like you
have to be a likeable person and so
people little is you just knew yeah and
but but for people to be likeable
person's you have to get to know them
and on Twitter it's very much instant
thoughts and snapchats very much instant
thoughts Facebook's instant instant
instant and it's all like your
personality coming out through through
something and I need find kids instead
of being like oh well I'm going to
illegally download the album because I
want to hear it they'll be like oh I
think they're a nice person I'm going to
support that and then and then they'll
go and buy the album and I think that's
a really important thing nowadays um
I've never been disproven because anyone
that comes across as a dick does not
sell that many records you think somehow
that aspect of your personality will
will come out in turn off people I
honestly do honestly I think you know
it's it's it's a lot different than back
in the day if I was a successful
musician in the 70s and there was a
newspaper article about me it could be
true it could not be true like if
there's it has TMZ footage now online on
YouTube and you watch it like it's there
it definitely happened so like it's um
yeah I think it's I think it's very
important to be a good person nowadays
in music and I found that everyone at a
certain level they're all nice
everyone's nice and everyone who's
mid-tier who's very um
what was the word very self-conscious
about about themselves and their talent
they're the ones who get a bit nasty
thing is let's not look like
breakthrough success is everything is
not is not what it seems
from from good things to bad things you
know everything has a kind of silver
lining and I think it's a healthy way to
live when you're in this industry to be
a little bit cautious because I went in
it within the ins that came into this
industry a very very wide eyes like
everything's great everyone's my friend
and then you kind of realize the more
the deeper you get into it it kind of
shrinks a little bit my dad always said
to me like if you don't need to get a
degree to do a job then go out and
experience it like you know if you want
to be a doctor go and get your grades
and stuff if you want to be a musician
your education is going to come from
doing shows writing songs practicing
meeting people networking so I just
start off as early as possible and do
that I've been influenced by many people
I've you know I've watched a Coldplay
DVD numerous times and taken little
tricks that called Chris Chris Martin
does with the wit with the crowd Eve
even if it's just like seeing this part
here or like one thing one thing I I
learnt quite quite early on as my friend
went to go and see him you too and they
I think they were singing streets have
no name or something and he'd like paid
money to be like front row and he was
there and then Bono goes about to get to
the chorus and Bali goes now you sing
like that and my friend was like does no
no no you sing I pay to come and see you
so so now every time every time when I
play I'll make sure I do the whole song
and then the sing-along happens so like
it's like I'll make sure people get what
they paid for
and then like because having the crowd
singing back is the most amazing thing
in the world and I kind of want to have
that for the whole concert but then also
you need to so I give as much as I can
and then you do this thing on basically
I was an actor before I was a musician
like I was in look like everyone you
said that did you say that
we're basically I was an actor but I was
it they do that that that was my main
thing I loved acting I was in loads of
theater groups I liked did that at
school all the time and then I quickly
realized like the weird thing is like I
can show you in 30 seconds how talented
I am music but I can't show you in 30
seconds how talented I'm acting online
and I I realized like I can't actually
have a successful acting career without
having a good part first then I just
don't like auditions I won't yeah for me
I that there was a point where I
auditioned for this ITV show and it was
a music and acting and I thought either
this will be fun and I got down to like
the final six and I said to myself if I
get this no more music just acting if I
don't normal acting just music and I
didn't and then just did music and then
it kind of all went well but I've always
wanted to act but I didn't want to do
something for the sake of it I'm gonna
play you a song okay so this is this is
my thing when when people go and be like
ah ah so talented you were born with
natural talent mmm no have a listen to
this right this is this is the have you
been played in public before no okay so
this is an exclusive ed Sheeran when he
was basically basically basically alone
I think when when people say artists are
born with talent you know you have to
you have to really learn and really
practice this is me playing guitar and
singing I'm gonna put in to promote like
this
okay
Oh
Oh
today walk
by this practice after that you practice
I did yeah no I just idea I probably
needed it so they can out loud 720
million views 720 million views on
YouTube how does that happen um that was
a conscious decision actually because
there's like certain certain things you
can do to make a music video go viral
which is like quite a difficult thing to
do in a day so you just have to do
something that makes someone click on a
video watch it and go I want to share
that with 10 people like that I have to
share that 10 people and I'm I never
appear in my music videos I've always
always make like a little little cameo
if I appear at all and I'm I'm not a
very svelte person I'm not I'm not very
talented at much else other than music
but I decided to tell you soon you're
getting in the way indeed well but but I
wanted to I wanted to make a music video
where I did a ballroom dance I wanted to
like a la So You Think You Can Dance but
like not on TV reality like I trained on
til 5 hours a day to learn this ballroom
dance shot the music for the owners so I
never wear suits either like it was
basically doing the opposite of it what
anyone thought I was as an artist and
then seeing and then everyone was like
oh that's weird
and then they shared it with lots of
other people and then it just kind of
blew up but the reason I chose it for
that song is I knew that song was the
biggest song on the album so to do the
like most standout video for the biggest
song when you combine them it both blows
up thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because houssam as he
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Ed Sheeran's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you leave it
in the comments and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon oh so cool are we recording